- Let's see what this excuse is.
- Doop, doop, doop, doop,
there they go. Hey.
- Where you been, man?
We been here for a hour.
- Had to make a stop.
- What is that?
- What is that? This is
my business, is what it is.
- Show us. Come on.
- I'm not showing you nothing.
Do you understand
what's going on today, guys?
- Tell us.
- I am going
into the legendary
Ben's Chili Bowl.
You want to know who else
has been here?
A bunch of black leaders, okay?
- Like who?
- Malcolm X,
Doctor Martin Luther King.
- That's two.
- What's the guy with the--
the jeans that got
the jacket to match him?
Barack. Barack Obama.
- He never wears jeans.
- Well, then you don't know him
like I know him.
I've seen him in jeans
several times.
The bottom line,
these are all black men
that are changing the world.
Looks to me like another
black leader
is walking in this place
that needs to be recognized.
- You do standup.
You're not a black leader.
- This man not a black leader,
Harry?
- Don't do this.
- Huh?
Telling me that, right there?
- He got a picture of himself.
- Don't do this.
- I got--what I got is history.
Okay? And there's a place
for me in here.
You know, Barack Obama is
on his way out the office.
Sounds to me like a space
on the wall just opened up.
- Kev, you're not
gonna go in here
and ask them to put you
on the wall.
- Damn if I won't.
- Did they ask you
to bring your picture?
- It ain't about what they ask.
It's about what you want.
- Don't do this.
- I'm doing it.
- Don't do it.
- Doing it.
- I can't believe--
- Don't do this. Don't.
- Kev, don't do this.